brian is with us in Michigan hey Brian
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
thank you for taking my call
sure what's up a lot the question for
you you know my fiance and I we have
been on your plant for about five months
now and we've been able to play off
$20,000 in debt where to go and my
question for you is though I try to get
other friends and family on your plan
and I've already had one or I think I
already had one friend that says that
sometimes when I talk about your plan
and what I've been able to do myself
that I come across as maybe as like as a
show-off and stuff like that so my
question for you is how do I approach
family and friends and talk about why
your plan works and why they should you
know get on your plan without coming
across as you know just full of myself
or something like that you know what I
mean I don't think that persons are real
friend yeah Dave and I mean I try to get
people on I try to get people on your
plan and let them know hey you know this
is what I've been able to do I mean look
that's not the point I mean the point is
if you're winning at anything and your
friend says your show-off that's just
somebody's jealous it's not a friend
yeah I mean I got a friend that lost 200
pounds okay and I don't think he's a
show-off I'm proud of him I'm happy for
him yeah he's changed his whole life his
whole physical appearance has changed
completely
it's absolutely amazing he was a big old
boy you know and he's in great shape now
and I'm so proud of it I'm not I don't
think he's a show-off and he talks about
food and eating and you know exercise
till I'm sick of hearing about it
honestly but I'm still proud of him he's
my friend I'm happy for me and pray I'm
celebrating his success with him and so
you know this is how it's sometimes how
you gauge the people you are going to
spend time with again you know you don't
want to be obnoxious about how you're
doing it but just Kass
I'm sorry if it sounds bad but I'm just
so excited I'm this is the first time
I've ever had a handle
this thing in it money used to just beat
the snot out of me and I was so bad at
it and now I'm winning you know I've got
a bunch of this debt paid off and I'm
fired up and you don't have to you know
be obnoxious Dave Ramsey fan you have to
do that you know to be obnoxious about
the fact you did all you're doing is
just going I celebrate with me I'm
having some victory here but if you
can't celebrate your own family your own
friends scoring a touchdown and jump up
and down and yell with them and say this
is awesome then and that's on them
there's not a really a certain way you
do that you know manners dictates you
don't talk about yourself all the time
that be part of it I guess but other
than that I mean really maybe just some
of these people are they just you know
they're just revealing who they really
are in your life